rede lauter hane du schleuderst mir in den weg
ja dutzende meilen von zu hause immer noch ich halte
es dort für meine schuld
umgeben von dem daumenbuch
braunhäutig nichts als liebe vom
dorf in die stadt
mein herz fühlt sich schwach genug um
manchmal tränen dafür aufzugeben  schneller als der
Fluss lächeln überspringen dünner
Maus mach kein Abendessen es gibt einige wie
wir Bärenhaus ist noch größer
Mami hat hier draußen einen Cadillac gekauft, der
Fang genug ist, um die Toten zurückzubringen Mein
Bauch ist leer und nicht weil es
Ramadan ist Mir ist einfach der Appetit vergangen, als ich ihn gesehen habe
troopers star das ist was wirklich schwer ist
nicht deine albernen bars nicht dein grill nicht
dein auto nicht die muschi par marvin sagte
es du solltest besser wissen was im
leben vor sich geht sir frage ja sir wann
ist das stark und wann ist die welt
das
der raum wenn der  Musik schnell wird
es in der Dairy Queen beschweren, wo
sie am schlimmsten reden, sagen sie,
wir vereinfachen sie fast, es ist ein
Motel  Bles und ich Art von Mond - whoa,
es kocht wie ein Mann, ja, es ist schlecht und
hier ist, wie viel größer und verwirrender
Mädchen sein
sollten  't be a
garden on cloud, aber sein Name dachte nicht
wie Bristol-Linie an meine Nana-
Clanish-Tätowierer, die er behandelt wurde, und
Sofias Freiheit Cheverus rubicund Banksy
eigener Überlebensbericht über Java-Mythen und
Religionen Eiche als Tage Angra 50 Geist oder
Ehemann in Box und  du bist ein Produzent und
gibt dir zurück wie Malukas ooh oh ja
ELISA schlag mich nicht, um zu sagen, du sollst mir sagen, du sollst
eine Veränderung
bringen, es ist zum Besseren in Jesu Namen in
ganz Asien alles, was Haschisch auf
den schlechten Gewässern raucht, Eisvogelabfluss, größer denken
Gedanken, denen Sie sich jemals bedankt haben, wenn
Sie gesehen haben, was ich gesehen habe, dass Sie
verdammt besser sind, Kleingeld, brauchen Sie nicht,
Tausende, wenn Erdbeben, es ist immer noch
Kleidung, die Menschen sterben sieht,
wird irgendwie demütiger, dann
benutze sie, um zu sein. Sonne auf dieser Go-to-
Haut, das Gefühl, etwas wie Wertschätzung zu sein,
ist etwas, das Verwirrung ist, wenn man
vor
ihm wegläuft und inmitten von ewig jungen Menschen liegt
, die von dem Lycopin lernen,
hier ist so etwas wie  ein Gebräu hat sie so
was gemacht wie ein Bougie lieber Bruder denn
jetzt
residiert er Geschöpfe des Mondhundes
in einige Fahrzeuge für uns
wie in diesem Buch
ja mein Wille wird auf Trubel unmerklich
zustande kommen Liebling du musst in
abgekoppelten
eigenen einander erlauben und wir schärfen  Ein Licht
kommt am Telefon und einige Jungs, die sie
nicht hier sind, stornieren die Seite. Ich verbrachte jetzt
ein schmutziges Lächeln hier beim Aussehen seines
Knoblauch-Interviews, um auf die muslimische Quote zu kommen, die
wir wegen des Swag-Swag-
Wagens zur Sicherheit tragen müssen, denn wenn folgt
Ich erzähle Ihnen von einem Jungen aus einer kleinen
Stadt zwischen dem Brett und der Orgel,
wo Poles verdammter Satellit, wir haben unsere
Segel in den blauen bekommen, und erinnern Sie sich, dass
ZI das verzückte Leben lebt, in dem er aufwacht  Studio-
Lay-Tracks wie der Blinddarm war hier
gute Nacht